[Musica]
no no no
no
no te lo aspetti
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi siamo qui
riuniti per celebrare il funerale del
gusto un tempo si diceva che noi
italiani di tennessee mo le redini dello
stile dell'arte della cucina ecco dopo
il video di oggi io credo che verranno
operato non solo alle persone che hanno
infangato il nome del nostro popolo in
modo ma anche tra i nemici del paese
perché faremo la pasta col ketchup per
fare sta pasta de merda avremmo bisogno
di pasta il male minore lubrificante
alimentare ritenzione idrica in grani e
che ricordo un 12 anni fa quando
lavoravo come cameriere all'interno di
un ristorante alla stazione termini di
roma lavoratori per un 2 netti per me
sono andato e ha chiuso il ristorante
perché io e ratatouille a che cosa un
sorcio ricordo però questo giorno in cui
questa bambina mi chiese delle penne
lisce scondite alle quali ha poi
aggiunto il ketchup quel giorno ho perso
una parte della mia innocenza che è una
parte che io non ho più ripreso in tutta
la verità io ricordo che non lasciata lì
dentro quel piatto e non l'ho mai più
ripresa indietro ecco perché è curioso
che io oggi farò esattamente quello che
ha fatto lei ma con più stile perché
cercherò di utilizzare delle tecniche da
ristorante fighetto che risulta tura
della pasta le cose mi piacciono a me
per fare alla fine degli spaghetti alla
chitarra per di più cioè di una buona
marca che è la mia barca preferita che
non vi dico o perché non mi ha mai dato
una lira e vennero siete indovinate qual
è la mia pasta preferire ovviamente
ragazzi non sto parlando di paste
artigianali perché c'è stato da alcune
assurde ma non le trova facilmente al
supermercato e ovviamente fatemi sapere
qua sotto secondo voi qual è la pasta
che invece non sopporto ragazzi come
sempre siccome io mi sto volando per voi
per provare questa cosa che so che
volete vedere perché io stesso sono
sovra eccitato all'idea di assaggiare
dopo 33 anni di vita la vasta col
ketchup perché è un abominio culinario
estero che non ho mai provato e che ho
sempre criticato ma sapere e potere io
vi chiedo di scrivere questo canale cioè
perché mi faccia il culone magno sta
merda e non è giusto che voi state
solamente lì a deridermi a scrivermi
anche dei commenti
di odio tipo dio imbarazzante cioè o ci
stiamo dentro insieme se non è facile
dare una pacca quando le cose vanno bene
è una spinta quando io sono sul ciglio
del burrone troppo facile è una storia
tragica
non a caso il suo vestito di nero oggi è
lutto è una puntata di cucina buttata
triste pezza e la parte buona che smacco
questa bambina che ha fatto non possiamo
tenerli share
mettiamo la pace all'interno della
pentola accendiamo il fuoco
mi dispiace devo fartelo scusa che
aggiungerò del sale il sale delle mie
lacrime quindi mettete poco sale non
troppo ricordo ancora quando quella
bambina mi guardò in questo sorriso che
io pensai butta stronza il suo era il
sorriso usano quelle bambini che sono
cattive kg guardata anche ho pensato
merda a parte gli scherzi ragazzi
parliamo un attimo seriamente questa è
la mia tecnica preferita so che alcuni
di voi manoscritto altri video nei quali
io faccio una risulta tura completa che
non amate particolarmente il sapore
dell'amido e tra parentesi nell'altro
video chiamato glutine quindi grazie a
chi mi ha corretto dicendomi guglielmo e
amido quello che rilascia la pasta
grazie e scusate ma sono stupido se no
vi farei un piatto stellato e invece qui
a farvi la vostra quel che dice no
perchè l'odio mi fa sentire vivo
comunque a parte gli scherzi io mi
ricordo che quando guardai quella
bambina non pensai merda pensai stronza
del caso i ragazzi tutti quanti anzi un
commento qua sotto a quella bambina che
adesso sarà un'adulta un commento di
odio inizio io spero tu muoia diritto
senza palato e papille gustative
provenire uno scherzo si è tenuto in
questo modo il lago che arriva in 18
anni ogni tot
aggiungo un po d'acqua come se fosse
brodo e continua a cucinare vuoi fare
facendo quella merda coperto ma lei la
pacifica in una padella un commento per
la bambina anche i bambini
la bambina che al mio ristorante nel
quale lavoravo ma se aprissimo un
ristorante un ristorante che si chiama
cucina buttata le persone tengono e
mangiano di merda mangiano le cose il
canale dovremmo creare un fondo di
donazioni tipo ognuno dono un euro
automaticamente sceglierà i soldi per
poter iniziare ad aprirti roma con sede
a roma per forza ragazzi poi però faremo
un franchise e apricena buttato andata
alla cugina le abbiamo tutti ragazzi
lisce scondite me li ricordo ancora
pallide che mi fissava le dicevano non
farci questo grazia ci almeno riga cd
quella che deve crescere proprio le
patatine lo mise sulla pasta orientale
no perché quella che fa la ricetta e
orientale quindi magari che la bambina
lo vedete quanto e cremosa vago
dire stefan piatto da perché ci permette
con tutte le ricerche che abbiamo io ce
la metto sempre il cuore prima di tutto
testa di capurro a profusione pagliuzza
realizzare e tagliuzzare sta per
arrivare il momento lo sapete stile
pronti in agam la pasta col ketchup
giriamo che ora lo andiamo a servire
nella ciotola del cane che hanno scuse i
miei amici di 23 bassi perché userò i
vostri piatti per mangiare brutto di
certo non è l'impianto mentale
soprattutto recuperato il momento di
assaggiare sta merda pasta col ketchup
prima volta nella mia vita che
l'assaggio un sapore particolare un
punto lo aspetti intensa dopo un possono
mettere a colla o se quella più e gli
editori di problemi di quadratura quelli
che dammi un parere onesto benissimo
malefatta moscia appositamente versare
il mood america atto cremosa capitolo
sentendo non è terribile non era battete
posso dito di buonissimi ma non è
terrificante domark ultimo assaggiato
[Risate]
l'odore non mi piace un sacco ma nemmeno
del burro cacao
ora sta cercando la battuta facile e un
sincero un piacere del pubblico sento
perché il culto pure la saggia tate
propria maniera netta di questa era
allora facciamo una cosa che fate 10
grammi di pasta un boccone vela cucinate
ci mettete un po di burro un po di cash
ap il assaggiate in una storia dove mi
taggate e voglio sapere se siete team
guglielmo tinge ma certe cose vietate
globalmente sei e mezzo york 5 aia
rovina band ufficiale aveva detto non è
un abominio non è che mi viene da mi
sento male però non è buona dai fatemi
sapere cosa ne pensate potete commentare
male solo se avete provato il mio stesso
procedimento
detto ciò scusate scappo che devo
rinnova il passaporto fare i bagagli
espatriare
[Musica]